foreign
wait
I should warn you before you step inside
the house this could change the course
of your entire life I'm not afraid of a
couple goes
you say that now
[Music]
this Mansion is unhinged
these ghosts definitely don't want to
leave
death lurks around every corner
God give us a break there's so many bad
people in the world haunt them amen
I do like surprises is anybody else
seeing this
we're gonna fight whether we like it or
not or else we're stuck here for
eternity
if this comes down to an exorcism
for one more
friend was mugged he was tall he had
hair that was sticking out of a what a
top hat Top Hat yes yeah yeah it's a top
hat you would pull a rabbit out of it
probably uh eyes they were a bit uh
something nice like a raccoon when they
set back
and he was smiling like yeah like that
exactly is this the man who mugged you
wow you just did that just now